[Music]
hey America hey America hey America I
know things are crazy right now travel
bans executive orders unintelligible
tweets at 2am we're all overwhelmed but
listen the ACLU was on it the ACLU has
had your back for almost 100 years
teaching evolution in schools the ACLU
did that in trouble to need a good
lawyer you get a lawyer and you get a
lawyer and you get a lawyer and you get
a lawyer the ACLU did that the
segregating schools the ACLU did that
the right to marry who you want the ACLU
did that twice a woman's right to choose
the ACLU did that over 40 years ago and
that's when we need to keep an eye on
everybody right now we're all scared and
angry but the ACLU has been fighting for
our rights since 1920 voting rights
LGBTQ rights a woman's right to choose
privacy immigration religious freedom
free speech these are the pillars upon
which the ACLU was built and they're all
under attack right now but don't worry
all that work that they've been doing
they have been preparing for this fight
so what do we need from you your
dedication your vigilance and your money
yeah we need your money make it rain do
you have any idea where airport Wi-Fi
costs for all those lawyers who are
writing emergency habeas motions on a
Saturday night with your help we got
this we got this we got this
you
you
[Music]